okay so here are the questions AK are
you encouraged by last month's ruling
that North Carolina's legislative maps
are unconstitutional yes I know you
spent a lot of time working on the
gerrymandering issue yes the it sounds
like a joke to the audience I'm very
very care well North Carolina listen
both sides have done it for many years
but I think in North Carolina oh it was
so so crazy so crazy that people had to
step in and say something and well just
to give the stats I think there were
thirteen legislative districts nine were
Republican and the state was dead even
yes so I mean there really is the
summary though of what that is what is
happening there it's politicians picking
the voters yes and that's all it is
versus anyway right I mean it's a you
know that's another reason why we have
to worry is that the Democrats don't
have to just win have to win so big to
overcome the cheating the Democrats
don't play dirty they need to learn to
play a little dirty I mean if this when
they go low we go high you go low go to
the side and give a noogie when they're
not looking I mean that's the answer I
mean you know it's there you don't come
to a gun fight with a knife if the other
guy's got a gun you got to bring a gun
that's it I mean simple working on this
done they're bringing a covered dish
I think with Trump looking so much like
he's he's a combination of unhinged and
not polite and all these kind of things
I think the opposite is in fact don't go
down to that level because you're
selling yourself is the alternative that
you want to have a country where we
don't treat each other that badly
anymore vote for me if you want the
country where we call each other scum
vote for the other by there's a way of
playing dirty without using terms like
human scum when I say play dirty play to
win play to win play hard in your face
just don't they there's a wimpiness to
the Democratic Party and you said
something so truth Donald Trump's
essence of his brand is strength whether
you like them whether you hate them
right there is a strength there and
that's what people follow and the
Democrats I have never seen a Democrat
in this iteration this group that
projects strength and that's concern
okay
depends how you define scrap all a false
strength that Trump I think that's all
false that strength oh it's always
easier music underneath it yeah he's a
coward you know projected his right but
his sorry I didn't mean I think that
harshness is a false proxy for strength
that's what this president is I think
that you can be strong and sweet
compassion is a kind of strength and I
think you know one of the reason I like
having the congresswoman on the show is
incredible forensic background
incredible incisiveness but not
everything is about somebody else having
to suck in her analysis and I think that
that's a big difference and I think
there's an angle for that you know why
does more you know why do your editorial
comments in that last segment resonate
so much because even though there's a
rapier wit that you know there's an edge
to it it's not everybody else has to
lose for you to win and I think that
that's what people are really hungry for
they're sick of everything being a nail
and him being a ham and if you want to
talk about how Democrats can win it's
having a positive affirmative vision of
the future instead of just harping on
Donald Trump you couldn't oh you know
obsessively Pope
Donald Trump I was a losing proposition
what you can't harp on is how Donald
Trump is gonna hurt and continue to hurt
your life I've never made a chart but I
think it's fair criticism I hear you you
know in my district is we don't know
what Democrats always stand for right
what's your hat like Donald Trump has
his hat make America great again
what's your hat right and I think it's
important that we articulate that
especially talking about people's
pocketbooks and their kids because for
everyone who's on Twitter and the
audience here that is not where my
district is my district wants their
government to run just basics the basics
and until we can articulate how we're
gonna help people we're just gonna be
clamoring clamoring to get and compete
with Donald but doesn't that get you in
a quite and a problem though isn't
clamoring to help people things like the
Medicare for all and all these other
things which are examples of trying to
help people's real problems but they
also give ammunition to the enemy or the
other side who would say that's
socialized medicine or you know we have
another socialist who wants to do
Medicare for all and you can't afford it
but Medicare for all might be seen as a
way to help more Americans and 60
million Americans that they can't have
their choose their private insurance
you're gonna lose an election right and
these people are smoking crack you know
forget about not even pill not even
paint being able to pay for 34 trillion
dollars my grandfather was a cop okay
and my mother was a schoolteacher and
they worked really hard to put me in a
position where I can buy the kind of
insurance I want and if I can't or the
people on this panel I can't buy for my
children we are going backwards we're
[ __ ] Denmark okay but remember the
problem wasn't that you couldn't buy
insurance is that you could buy
insurance and still end up broke when
you needed it at the end I mean the
insurance had too many loopholes so you
get the government in to help that and
then we end up you know and I have to
say no matter who's up on that debate
stage every single Democrat wants to
protect health care and make it more
affordable whereas the Republicans want
to take it away and make it more
expensive period there you go that
almost fits on a hat
what yeah well that brings up an
interesting point I was gonna ask you
separated of time I don't think the
networks including CNN should be doing
the debates because I think networks
have to make a profit and I think when
you have to make a profit you have to
put on a show and a debate shouldn't be
a show used to be the League of Women
Voters who did it you know or have
professors do it what about all three
stations at once to remember run it on
all three networks right you wanna days
- yeah that's right except there's more
than three networks now exactly you have
to run it on all five totally stream it
and you know it would be a little more
difficult but what do you think about
that I think that the part fo Chris
hookers watching I I think that you know
the the boss has made good decisions
about what to do to have CNN positioned
right but when you have the party in
control of it they have an extraordinary
amount of leverage how many people are
going to be there what kinds of
questions and if you don't hit the
targets that they're asking you to you
may not get another at-bat and I think
that's a lot of leverage and I think
that if you can decentralize it and have
it be special interest groups that throw
the debates that dynamic goes out the
window well that I would hardly call the
League of Women Voters a special
interest group what is the interest room
voting yeah I mean I'm making your point
I'm saying that if you remove it from
the parties oh yeah and put it into you
know okay
these other non you know specifically
partisan groups you decentralize the
power okay Dan Carla what do you think
of polling that says seventy percent of
Americans believe the u.s. is on the
edge of a civil war I don't love polling
because I thought we got burned on a
couple of elections following the polls
I'm not sure to say it's 60 percent okay
it's only six out of ten Americans would
think run the verge of a civil war
I think the proto bad thing we are not a
G of everything not a good day it is a
bad thing we are on the verge of Civil
War what you want you want to see was it
true the war Trump loses he will tell
people to take to the streets that's
what I get that he's not going one step
further than he's gonna say and the
streets and umpire I think his work in
the world series too
you see this story he tweeted out what
is there something like if they try to
impeach my president I'm getting my
maggot and my a K and yeah and getting
in the streets and like I can't really
comment on baseball cuz I'm involved
with it but I don't think that's right
especially from somebody who's supposed
to be impartial calling balls and
strikes this this reality show that's
got a little shits and giggles in it
ain't gonna be any shits and giggles
left tip he loses one we're going to
Guantanamo Bay together you're friends
with Kelly and Conway I'm friends with
Ann Coulter we're gonna need these
people
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you